A video that shows a group of men robbing a jewelry store in the town of Northampton, England yesterday.
And who foiled them?
A grandmother with a sense of justice and a handbag.
Nick Watt tells us what happened.
A brazen smash and grab in full swing.
Look at that guy walking past like there's nothing happening.
They're trying to steal watches from a store window.
Then out of nowhere, a galloping grandma.
Armed with a handbag and a whole lot of chutzpah.
Bang, bang, bang.
She is Ann Timson.
She's in her 70s.
And now she's hailed as "supergran".
Like any good superhero, she is shunning the limelight.
"I just wanna be left in peace," she told her local newspaper.
Let's see it again.
Here she comes.
"I don't know what happened next," supergran told the paper,...
"I just kept swinging."
She's got groceries in that handbag.
She's like a boxer with a horseshoe in his glove.
"I landed several blows against one lad," said our heroine, "and brought him to the ground."
Not one of them hit her back.
Why? Their mothers taught them to respect their elders?
Truth is in Britain, we revere old ladies particularly those with handbags.
And another just joined that pantheon.
"Good on ya supergran," reads one web post.
"If I knew who you were, I'd buy you a drink."
"Supergran, I'd buy you dinner."
Nick Watt, ABC News, London.